So we need to figure out
what 46 plus 43 is.
Let me write it down again
and I'll write it like
this: 46 plus 43.
What we do here is we just first
look at the ones place.
We literally have 6 ones plus 3
ones, or you could say 6 and
3, and 6 plus 3 is just 9.
6 plus 3 is 9, so
we have 9 ones.
And then you go to the tens
place, and there's two ways to
think about it.
You could view this as 4 plus
4 is equal to 8, but really,
the reality of what we're doing
since we're operating in
the tens place, this is really
40 plus 40 is equal to 80.
And we could do the same
problem expanded out.
This is the same thing
as 40 plus 6.
We've seen this before, right?
That's what 46 is.
And then 43 is the same
thing as 40 plus 3.
We've expanded these
out before.
And so when you add them,
when you add a 6 plus a
3, you get a 9.
When you add a 40 plus
a 40, you get an 80.
So you get 80 plus
9, which is 89.
And the whole reason why I did
this is I wanted to show you
that when you're adding 4's in
the tens place, you're really
adding 40's.
The fact that it's in the tens
place represents-- or the fact
that the 4 is in the tens
place shows that
it represents 40.
The fact that the 8's there
shows that it represents 80.